hey guys Ryan right here on the side of
the couch and Jerry here in front of
this table you can see we're gonna check
out the trailer the red band trailer
come or rated trailer for Scott Scott's
scouts guide to the zombie apocalypse
interesting people have been saying we
should check this out and I got a horse
Mac jer-bear over here so this is like
it's gonna be quirky and offbeat but
good-natured yeah like randomly violent
it's not randomly intentionally
yeah well intentional two people made it
yeah we don't know let's find out
she came on as a possible break pretty
handy I'm a scab make an actual Scout
yeah please thanks thanks yeah tonight's
big secret party pray everybody except
the douchebags and the neckerchief will
be going this could be the night of our
lives no zombies or conquer the town's
deserted dude look what the bouncer is
gone we should stick it there's like
nobody here
this is [ __ ] awesome dude something
wrong with your chest oh that's makeup
dummy
John go face
being effective from the Herot you a
stripper cocktail waitress going on [ __ ]
you eating each other like it any more
questions
[Music]
oh no that's actually kind of scary whoa
tonight we're Shauna being real Scouts
all about we're just gonna stand here
I'm gonna go save the world
[ __ ] yeah dude it's gonna Rodgers he
looks like [ __ ] he said I'm on fire
didn't care he tried to eat me
I think so let's kick some zombie ass
no we don't think we were real looks
like they got a bunch more money to
finish that movie halfway through that
Traverse to have the trailer like it
almost looks like the editing is
different and almost looks like it's
kind of more amateurish like oh this
might be like a really low budget movie
that kind of got bumped up and then
halfway through it's like Oh or you can
do all this like Dead Alive shouldn't
just blow heads up and yeah you know
have like really high production value
CG seems like it was it's it's like a
predictable kind of plot like okay you
know he's a scalp Cub Scout whatever
hears voice yeah like left-of-centre
dweeby occupation yeah that's gonna come
in handy when the zombie apocalypse
comes and then he bumps into like
superhot but also like not a member of
his immediate community girl he's a
badass chick there's a coming of age but
the thing is is like what do you want
from this kind of movie you want fun
zombie kills and you want some laughs
and thrills you know just a little bit
definitely this movie's gonna give it to
us J oh yeah I mean it looks like it's
got all that stuff and it also looks
like at least I feel like they're one of
the three movies this is attempting to
be is kind of like a really balls out
just kind of crazy monster movie kind of
like you would have seen in the 80s cuz
that whole thing with like the zombie
cat yeah and then a million more zombie
cats was like almost can't be in a way
and why I like that you know campy works
well for a boy scout yeah you know it's
like 80s camp it's got some throwback in
histology live it's got some that
b-movie fun vibe they're probably really
you know if they went like serious
they'd be really traumatized from that
stripper meant that you know
yeah and I'm wondering what their zombie
rules are cuz you know it's like I'm
like did it yeah she was like actually
stripping yeah I'm like I do they just
remember their past occupations like
muscle memory yeah and the one guy had
all this blood spill I am and I was like
it's like Tiffani Gunners mouth her eyes
he's got any and in a lot of other
zombie films that would
one way you get infected yeah so as a as
a horn getting caught up on the rules
yeah well the rules matter dude they do
as long as the movie itself you know
establishes what those are in the movie
yeah
like warm body like slightly okay I get
it or like how Twilight you know how
like Edward is you know he's a vampire
yes but he can be out in the Sun he just
shines really bright you know
yeah and they address that early on
mm-hmm he was beautiful thing it was
beautiful
that's what Kristen Stewart said you're
beautiful DX if she look she looks
scared you be scared too if you're in
that situation I think it was a great
acting choice innocent you know of all
them I mean it's awkward because like
she makes that same face she always
makes but like it wasn't a badly
delivered line if this film can borrow
more from Twilight I think this one will
be perfect no quote I don't quote gonna
do that for all you are taking you
seriously now continue taking me
seriously quote me on that yeah
everything said on this show is entirely
especially what I say anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the channel if you're
new to it you know what you can do you
know keep watching that too you can
subscribe to the reel rejects you could
also check out reasons to Jerry and dink
s Stubbs hosted by said Jerry on this
channel and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope or so suck up
Bruce Ren Bruce Ren I've watching some
of your videos youtube you and other
people's are awesome oh and he's in
Memphis Tennessee Oh makes sense why he
talks the way he does a lot in some of
your videos youtube you and other
people's are uh are awesome the best
Tennessee accent you'll ever get I don't
I don't know if Bruce was gonna
appreciate that or not this will
appreciate that Bruce Ren let's see what
you look like oh you got a picture with
your doggy you know what he looks like
what he looks like one of those guys is
like aw he's warm and friendly because
he has a dog but he uses the dog as a
manipulation tactic to lure people and
murder them that's what you look like
that's how maybe he's just in a hurry no
no he's he's a he's he's a serial killer
I don't know he looks like a very kind
person he looks like a serial killer
he looks like he loves his dog he's
probably gonna eat that dog one day no
don't eat your dog I mean that's just
too sick killing people's one thing
eating your dog that's inhumane